so it's possible that a lot of president  trump's late-term pardons  might not actually shield the people  that he pardoned we know that the trump  administration was perfectly capable of  writing the broadest possible pardons  for example with michael flynn  he received a pardon on any and all  possible crimes arising out of the facts  for which he was  charged you rarely see pardons like that  it harkens back to gerald ford pardoning  richard nixon it's extremely rare but  they know how to do it the thing is the  trump administration barely followed any  procedure whatsoever so it's not  surprising that some of these pardons  might be defective like the pardons  against bannon manafort stone  papadopoulos  these might actually not provide any  protection for these reprobates  all of these pardons were drawn  incredibly narrowly and prosecutors  might be able to charge other crimes  i'll explain why in part two